E
ONGOING BATTLE.
DAN: THANKS FOR THE UPDATE, IT'S
HARD TO IGNORE THE ENERGY CRISIS
HAPPENING AROUND THE WORLD RIGHT
NOW.
EVERY TIME YOU GO TO THE GAS
STATION AND FILL UP YOUR TANK,
YOU ARE REMINDED OF THE ONGOING
DAMAGE TO YOUR POCKETBOOK.
I PERSONALLY HEARD IT, I'VE BEEN
AT GAS STATIONS, I HERE AND
WATCH PEOPLE WITH AUDIBLE SIZE
AND LOOKS ON THEIR FACES OF
AUDIBLE SHOCK WHEN THEY SEE THE
TALLY.
I WISH I COULD TELL YOU THE
BIDEN HAVE BEEN INSTRUCTIONS
FAILURE, THEY ARE INCOMPETENT.
BUT THE TRUTH IS, WHAT IS
HAPPENING RIGHT NOW IS
INTENTIONAL.
>> UNDER MY PLAN OF A TRADE
SYSTEM, ELECTRICITY RATE WOULD
SKYROCKET BECAUSE OF GREENHOUSE
GASES, POWER PLANTS, NATURAL
GAS, WHATEVER, YOU NAME IT,
NEVER THE INDUSTRY, THEY WOULD
HAVE TO RETROFIT OPERATIONS THAT
WILL COST MONEY AND PASS MONEY
ONTO CONSUMERS.
>> THE RISING GAS PRICES OVER
THE LONG-TERM MAKES A STRONGER
CASE FOR DOUBLING DOWN
INVESTMENT AND FOCUS ON CLEAN
ENERGY OPTIONS SO WE ARE NOT
RELYING ON FLUCTUATIONS AND
OPEC.
DAN: PAT THEIR WORDS.
NOT MY WORDS.
REMEMBER THIS JUMP?
JENNIFER GRANHOLM LAUGHING UP
THE IDEA OF INCREASE IN OIL
PRODUCTION?
>> WHAT IS THE GRANHOLM PLAN TO
INCREASE OIL PRODUCTION IN
AMERICA?
[LAUGHTER]
THAT IS HILARIOUS.
I HAD THE MAGIC WAND ON THIS, AS
YOU KNOW OIL IS A GLOBAL MARKET.
DAN: IT'S NOT HILARIOUS, IT NOT
HILARIOUS THAT'S LIKE YOUR JOB,
YOU HAVE ONE JOB, ENERGY
SECRETARY, TOTALLY NOT
HILARIOUS.
HERE'S THE TRUTH, EVERYTHING WE
SEE RIGHT NOW IS EXACTLY WHAT
THE ADMINISTRATION AND OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION WANTS, NONE OF
THIS IS NEW.
LET'S BREAK DOWN WHAT THEY ARE
DOING USING THE LEFT WORK.
AFTER MONTHS OF BUYING OIL FROM
VLADIMIR PUTIN, THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION FINALLY BANNED
OIL.
TERRIFIC EXCEPT THE ONLY PLAN TO
REPLACE IT IS GET RID OF FOSSIL
FUELS ALTOGETHER WHICH HAS BEEN
THERE ENERGY SUICIDE PLAN FROM
DAY ONE.
>> LONG-TERM MAKES IT AN EVEN
STRONGER CASE FOR DOUBLING DOWN
OUR INVESTMENT AND FOCUS ON
CLEAN ENERGY OPTIONS.
IF WE DO MORE TO INVEST IN CLEAN
ENERGY AND OTHER SOURCES OF
ENERGY, THE PRESIDENT VIEW IS
THAT WE, IT'S A HUGE ADVANTAGE
TO US TO BE A LEADER IN THE
CLEAN ENERGY TRANSITION.
>> ACCELERATED TRANSITION PLAN
DO WHAT WE CAN, IT MEANS NO ONE
HAS TO WORRY ABOUT THE PRICE OF
THE PET GAS PUMP IN THE FUTURE.
DAN: A SIMPLE GUY, I WAS A
QUEENS KID FROM NEW YORK, LET ME
GET THIS STRAIGHT, SUPPOSED TO
BUY INTO THE LONG-TERM CLEAN
ENERGY AS A SOLUTION TO THE
ENERGY CRISIS BOUGHT OUT BY THE
RUSSIAN INVASION OF UKRAINE
RIGHT NOW.
DRILLING FROM A DOMESTIC OIL AND
REINSTATING THE PIPELINE IS NOT
A SOLUTION BECAUSE ONLY A
LONG-TERM FIX?
WHAT IS IT, MAN?
LONG-TERM SOLUTION OR NOT?
>> WOULD PRESENT BIDEN EVER HAVE
EXECUTIVE ORDER THAT STOPPED THE
CONSTRUCTION OF THE KEYSTONE
PIPELINE?
>> ARE YOU SUGGESTING THAT WOULD
SOLVE THE GAS PRICE ISSUE?
>> IT WOULD MAYBE AFFECT PRICES
FASTER THAN GETTING THE WHOLE
COUNTRY ON FOSSIL FUEL.
>> I DON'T THINK IT WOULD.
DAN: GAS LINE HERE, THIS IS
ASTONISHING.
DO WE WANT A LONG-TERM SOLUTION
OR NOT A LONG-TERM SOLUTION?
JOE BIDEN ALSO IS DENYING NOW
THE WERE ON FOSSIL FUEL EVER
HAPPENED.
>> SIMPLY NOT TRUE MY
ADMINISTRATION OR POLICIES ARE
HOLDING BACK DOMESTIC ENERGY
PRODUCTION, THAT'S SIMPLY NOT
TRUE.
DAN: HERE IS THE SAME GUY, JOE
BIDEN, IT'S NOT BIZARRE OLD BOAT
JOE BIDEN, THIS IS THE SAME GUY
DESTROYING DOMESTIC OIL INDUSTRY
IS ADMINISTRATION'S BAN ON.
>> NO MORE SUBSIDIES FOR FOSSIL
FUEL, NO MORE DRILLING ON
FEDERAL LAND, NO MORE DRILLING
INCLUDING OFFSHORE, NO ABILITY
FOR THE OIL INDUSTRY TO CONTINUE
TO DRILL.
AND.
DAN: IF YOU BELIEVE THERE LIES,
ANTI- OIL POLICY STILL EXIST,
THERE HAS TO BE A SCAPEGOAT SO
THEY HAD TO BLAME IT ON THE WAR
IN UKRAINE.
>> CAN'T DO MUCH RIGHT NOW.
DAN: LISTEN, LET'S SUM THIS UP,
THE LEFT WANT A DESTRUCTIVE
SUICIDAL UNWORKABLE
TECHNOLOGICALLY UNFEASIBLE
PRE-NEW DEAL SO BADLY THEY THINK
THEY CAN FORCE THE MIDDLE CLASS
TO LITERALLY BUY INTO IT BY
MAKING YOU ALL CHOOSE BETWEEN
PAYING MORE FOR AN ELECTRIC CAR
OR PAYING FIVE OR SIX OR $7 A
GALLON OF GAS.
THEY WILL USE THE HORRIFIC WAR
WAGED BY RUSSIA AND UKRAINE AS
POLITICAL COVERAGE FOR THE ANTI-
FOSSIL FUEL AGENDA.
JUST HOW FAR ARE THEY WILLING TO
GO?
THEY ARE WILLING TO BUY OIL FROM
VENEZUELA, COMMUNIST AND DEATH
TO AMERICA IRANIANS BEFORE
ALLOWING AMERICANS HERE TO DRILL
OUR OWN OIL?
>> IS IT YOUR EXPECTATION
IRANIANS DO COME BACK ONLINE IF
THERE IS A DEAL ON THE NUCLEAR
AGREEMENT?
>> THE AGREEMENT FOR THE DEAL IS
D NUCLEAR ASKED IRAN, THAT IS
THE REASON FOR THE DEAL IF THERE
IS PRE-SUPPLY.
DAN: DO YOU WANT ME TO TURN THE
THERMOMETER UP TO 107?
HERE'S THE CHERRY ON TOP, IT'S
YOUR PATRIOTIC DUTY TO FOOT THE
BILL.
>> THE COST IS WELL IN THE
UNITED STATES, DEFENDING FREEDOM
IS GOING TO COST, IT'S GOING TO
COST IS AS WELL IN THE UNITED
STATES.
REPUBLICANS AND DEMOCRATS
UNDERSTAND REPUBLICANS AND
DEMOCRATS ALIKE HAVE BEEN CLEAR
WE MUST DO THIS.
DAN: LET'S SUM IT ALL UP, OIL
COMPANIES ARE SUPER GREEDY BUT
NOT TAKING ADVANTAGE OF TAKING
MONEY?
THAT MAKE SENSE ONLY IF YOU ARE
A LIBERAL OF COURSE.
THEY WANT TO SHUT DOWN THE
KEYSTONE XL PIPELINE SAY IT
WOULD HAVE NO IMPACT ON PRICES.
LONG-T